so
i was hearing a little bit about how
this is one of your first stunt heavy
projects so of everything you had to do
in
1978 what kind of you know behind the
scenes movie magic made you go
like huh i can't believe that's what it
takes to make it look like that on
screen
i mean yeah it's a lot of a lot of
make-believe
um specifically i think in the first
scene
when the sunnyvalers have like hung me
up by the tree which is just so cruel
but um
i have my hands up there was no tension
on that rope whatsoever so everything
that i was doing that was just like
me kind of make believing that there was
any tension um
yeah so it's but it's amazing how that
like can translate on screen because i
remember watching that being like
oh wow that actually looks like looks
like it was hurting me so yeah
i guess it worked i have to get into
like the blood and gore of it all too
i just i want to know everything about
shooting
ziggy and cindy's last stand maybe first
off there
given what you had just said about the
opening what can we do
when you're on set filming something
like that in order to make you feel
you know the intensity of a scene like
that i mean
she's just she's great and just the
energy that you created on set and
the way that she can like talk to you
and get you like worked up and ready to
go
um it's great and then also just i mean
those killers are just so
terrifying so there's really there's not
a lot that you have to do because it's
genuinely just so
scary and then we had amazing stunt
coordinators that like told you exactly
the specifics of how you should react
um just in terms of like your movement
and everything
um so yeah we had a lot of good people
helping uh
make sure that we that we sold it i
warned you we're doing spoilers
i have to ask about i guess i don't know
how else to phrase this but the
stabbiness of it all
because there are some really brutal
kill scenes in the series leading up to
that moment but
i guess i was just kind of shocked and
in a good way i mean by
how long that lasted and also the fact
that they did that with your two
characters
in particular i know i mean it's brutal
like my mom my mom stopped watching at
that point she couldn't take it
could not take it and i couldn't either
i was just like oh my god it's kind of
it's very disturbing to watch this but
um
yeah in the moment i really had no idea
what was happening um
because you know obviously like my eyes
were closed and like there was you know
blood everywhere so seeing it
how it actually looked was was pretty
cool i'd never worked with um
mouth blood before so that was that was
an exciting first for me
sometimes we play a movie and tv themed
would you rather and that makes me think
of one of the questions we often ask and
it's
would you rather have to fake sneeze or
fake vomit in a scene and let's throw in
would you
rather have to fake sneeze fake vomit or
fake cough up blood in a scene
i mean honestly the coffin of blood it
wasn't as hard as i thought it was gonna
be
it was actually kind of fun um
yeah so i guess i would have to do the
the coughing up blood because i think
i've i think i've got that down at this
point
can confirm uh did you get the chance to
cross over at all with gillian while you
were shooting so you could discuss the
character transition at all
no i still have never met her to this
day
so youtube are so convincing too oh good
i'm so glad yeah i hadn't even seen any
videos of her performance so i was
really nervous
it was you know just hoping that our
interpretations of the character on
paper
were able to translate on screen in the
same way and kind of carry over into the
films and
and and seem like the same person i was
really glad that that it did
and a lot of the characteristics were
the same but yeah never met her never
discussed the character but
hopefully i get to meet her soon yes
very very very impressive job well done
in that department so
thank you with this one i know there was
a lot of stranger things crossover in
terms of the folks behind the camera and
also in front of it so when you jump
onto a set like this does it kind of
feel like
an extension of that home or still a
completely different project
it's a different story i mean yeah there
was a lot of we filmed in atlanta
so a lot of the crew was um the same
and so that was really nice it was kind
of comforting to see these people that i
was familiar with
and also lee our director uh is married
to ross one of the duffer brothers so i
had known lee since i was like 14 years
old
so it was really exciting to get to work
with her because it was something that i
had been wanting to do
when did you uh first start talking
about doing this project together
the script just kind of got sent to me
like the audition got sent to me and i
was like
oh i mean it's lee like i have to do
this i have to go after this and then
i met with her we've read through some
scenes talked about the project
and then um we did a chemistry read with
um emily who plays cindy and yeah and
then after that
we're like okay let's do this and i'm
just happy that it worked out
also in the stranger things sphere i do
definitely see some similar qualities
that ziggy
and max share just in terms of who they
are as people and
i also have the loss of a sibling on my
mind so having filmed
this before going back to that do you
find that any qualities of
ziggy's are coming through when you're
playing max now
it's hard to say um just because
depending on what season i feel like the
characters
we have a lot of time at being a series
the characters really grow and develop
and each season they're almost like a
different person
um so i guess there are a few
similarities
they're definitely two strong female
characters but
um one thing that did that i did
take with me from from fear street is
just like my experience with stunts now
i think i feel like
i've i've got a lot more experience and
that's
helped me along the way i like that
tease quite a bit
also i wanted to ask you something about
the stranger things season four
production schedule because i know it
was a very unique experience on that one
so
what would you say is one unique pro of
filming
season four something that's you know
better than ever and then
what's something that proved to be more
challenging that you had to adjust to in
order to overcome
i mean yeah so we started filming season
four
i don't even know when it was but it was
before the pandemic and then we had
we got like a month of filming done then
we had to stop
for i guess seven or eight months and
then we came back to work and things
were like completely different so i
think
the real challenging part was just
adjusting to the to the new
the new rules and the regulations that
were in place on set that was a big
adjustment
but yeah and i think we were just all
just so grateful to be able to work
and yeah we've been working working for
a while now and
and creating something really amazing
the scale of the show just gets bigger
and bigger each year
um so yeah it's just been really
incredible
to see where they're going with the
storyline which it's really amazing this
year and just how the stakes are just
so much higher higher than they've ever
been i don't envy you having to tease
that all the time but you got a lot of
people out there so excited and
all i want to do right now is tell
everybody out there how good you are in
fear street and how good fear street is
overall
i freaking loved it and cannot convey
that strongly enough
oh thank you so much